Raymond Strother is president of
Struther Duffy strother a democratic
political consulting firm his new memoir
falling up covers his years on the
campaign trail this talk from winning
connections a telephone polling and
political consulting firm in Washington
DC is about 50 minutes first of all I'm
John Jameson I present winning
connections and I want to thank all of
you for coming out here tonight first of
all there's some people want to thank
Connie my wife if she's working all the
time she won't be booked up thankful for
the food and drinks and putting this
together if you work for winning
connections raise your hand they've all
been helpful but uh stacee morgan in
particular stacy wherever you are is is
is much work that you've done on this
and as much busy work as I've made you
do I want to make sure I thank you um in
particular and just as far as family and
friends my daughter Savannah or friend
India and my mom building Jameson my
mother-in-law June Myers are here in ray
I did look ray the bad thing hopefully
there aren't too many people like my mom
here she said John I don't need a book
tonight I'll take yours later on but but
the purpose here is for everyone to take
books we want books and if you want to
buy oh you know I often get used what
you know we're we're asked quite often
why we do this because we're we're
political consulting firm we do you know
some of your familiar with what winning
connections does is basically we put
together telephone and voter contact in
internet programs for you know we work
for hundreds of candidates we work for
groups like near al and Planned
Parenthood and the Sierra Club and the
National Wildlife Foundation and asked
me an NEA and aft in other other labor
unions but that's kind of our day job
but but the reason that that that that
I'm that we're really got in this to
begin with this because we're about a
group of people who try to make ideas
reality that's at the end of the day
that that's when we get up in the
morning we're trying to do and we found
out that through having events like this
where we start talking about
it's helped make us better what we do
and that's why we've had people like a
edmund morris and juan williams and i'm
not sure if jack germond is here yet but
who's coming but he he also came here
and they've been great events and all of
them been fun but I've got to say
tonight is particularly special because
it's the first time we've got to do an
event for someone who was both a real
good friend and in a neighbor for a long
time in this race brother until ray and
sandy moved to Montana which was a big
loss for the Jameson family that's for
sure but but these are just a couple of
ways raised bed has helped a whole lot
of people and you'll see in the book
whether it's getting james carville
started or I've seen walle Clinton who
he's worked a lot with other consultants
here but uh but for every person he's
mentioned in here they're ten people
he's helped that or maybe maybe 50
people who aren't here like like me but
I can remember it wasn't that long ago
that uh i was in my basement I starting
this company and then couple times ray
ray called me and helped us out with the
things that turned out to be really good
opportunities for us and I was just so
pleased he had so much confidence well
sandy later on I found out that my wife
Connie was going to you quite often and
saying my John quit his job we're gonna
start so and and and you're responsible
don't worry honey we're not gonna let
you starve so so regardless of what your
motives were for helping me I i I'm
grateful and and it is personal and I'm
thinking of seeing my daughter had
reminds me of something else someone I
can trust a few years ago when or during
the winter and our d street was covered
in ice a raised dog Bucky who Savannah
was in love with we decided to we hit
Bucky out there we hooked a rope onto
him took off and Savannah was holding on
to anyway she hits it hit the pavement
pretty quick with her head but I knew
ray was someone I could trust them
because he didn't say a word to my wife
or his wife for up for long time after
yeah so what you know with with someone
like that we you know we're just
grateful we can do this but Ray you
you've been a good friend to my family
you've been so important this industry
in this book is if you haven't bought it
we got books for you free tonight but
what we're expecting you to do is to go
out and buy a book for your friends I
mean really I think it's a great story
it's my friends are in politics love it
we were talking to someone today though
who's not in this business at all who
came by here to read about 10 pages of
it and he said it's it's an incredible
story so I think some we want to talk
this book up because it's it's a it's
about a very special person his special
wife and we're just looking forward to
hearing about it and Ray is going to
talk about 25 or 30 minutes he's told me
he's time challenge so I'll nudge you
but and then we're looking forward to
good Q&A session afterwards so Raymond
please excuse the voice I've been had a
malady I don't think I'm contagious the
doctor said I wouldn't but anyway this
is I really want to thank John and
Connie not only they were neighbors they
were very good friends and this
organization here is such a good
political organization they do so much
good works i'm very proud to be here and
i recommend that anyone higher winning
connections when they have an
opportunity you can all didn't get that
he's happy and i see i see a lot of
friends in the audience about half of
you been in campaign wars with me here's
Doni Lynch I remember loading Dottie
Lynch in New Hampshire and the New
Hampshire primaries in the back of my
airplane in the back seat and she was
brave and she said she wouldn't have
done it had sandy not been in the front
seats you look a little frightened and
we flew back from New Hampshire and and
I have a little story probably for half
the people here something we've done
together and it's a truly a gathering of
insiders here and I'm proud to be called
an insider I do not mind that label at
all and I think there are a lot of great
people in this room a lot of great
people in our business the books call
falling up how redneck helped invent
political consulting let me tell you a
little bit about my definition of a
redneck because people are immediately
horrified by that
I did it really to install some people
but the kicks and in the face of the
establishment it's something who
sometimes made it difficult for me to
start in the stem because my quirky
accent but a redneck is by definition
today usually a poor white Southerners
who is awfully proud to the point of
arrogance I think that's pretty much me
and but the true definition came out of
out of northern England Scotland in this
turn of the route 17 10 the
Presbyterians there the rural
Presbyterians were called by the British
rednecks because obviously had rednecks
from plowing because they had to bend
over a plow and the British were always
afraid of the Scots the Scots are still
little crazy and they would pass the
riot act and in the riot act you could
confiscate a Scots property three or
more gathered together so it was a so
the rednecks had to band together and
they moved to North Ireland and when
they arrived there the Catholics call
them rednecks when they got there the
Presbyterian rednecks well these
rednecks from northern Scotland from
Ireland moved to the US and they landed
in Virginia and Georgia and settled
across the south that's why the south is
so redneck that's one reason that's
where the expression came from it wasn't
anything that we invented or somebody
invented insult us we'd been insulted
centuries before so so anyway this this
book falling up was inspired by three
books Hal rains great book fly fishing
through the midlife crisis where he was
brutally honest and I admired that Jack
Germans book fat man in a center seat
was brutally honest and I admired it and
jaws wit covers book no way to pick a
president which really set me to
thinking about the ramifications of our
own business and what we've done to the
system and what's it how we've helped
mold the system for good and bad so
those three books were very important to
me and I recommend that anyone who
hasn't read those three books by all
three of them because they're splendid
books
and they've meant a lot to me in my last
few years this book is a autobiography
but it's not about redemption is sort of
the search for redemption the struggle
for demp shin but it's mostly about the
evolution of political consulting I
started 1967 in Louisiana and a lot of
things have happened since then we've
evolved in this books about the
Darwinists struggle for survival the
strong take all the weak die and it's
about a lot of things that aren't
necessarily about me I tried to make it
about the industry i went into politics
of server religion my father thought
that poor people had no no chance at all
without politics that no voice no power
and the poor people could band together
as one they were ignored and voiceless
and so he always told me that politics
was very important so I went into
politics through journalism which I
thought was a noble cause to I was an AP
reporter and I thought it was a way to
help working people to tell the truth
because my father was concerned that the
truth was never told for the working man
so I went into politics show you how
democratic we were and I don't mean to
offend Republicans although I don't
matter particularly my mother was very
fundamentalist Baptist and I listened
all that but at night I prayed to Harry
Truman he was a guy in Washington that I
could see in the newspaper and he did
things so he was a guy understood so
Harry Truman became my oh my god among
gods at the time i'd like to read your
passage now called growing up in Texas
this is called a reading and I asked my
son I said you really think I should
read he said why he held hell they call
it a reading my son has a way of capsule
aiding things and it's called growing up
in Texas I came from Port Arthur Texas
my childhood home we were fierce
Democrats from the picket line against
the abuse of working people we knew that
if one dropped his guard for only a
minute the Republicans were have him by
the throat like a jungle predator
feeding on the week Republicans
individually were lent
sexless selfish cowards and we
collectively were strong workers were
sweat on their backs and dirt under
their fingernails could defeat the rich
capitalist the devout are young for
breakfast and built roads for their
Cadillacs and Packard's from the crushed
bones of working people workers had to
stand together shoulder to shoulder with
clubs in her hands and righteousness in
our hearts and to follow the fifth grade
I was sent to school on an urgent
assignment for my father I was to
correct the teachers misinterpretation
of history and explained to her that
Franklin Roosevelt and not George
Washington was the father of our country
Washington was just another aristocrat
who rose to power on the backs of dead
soldiers and working people he could
afford to throw dollars across the
Potomac and chopped down his family's
fruit trees because they had more money
and more trees but working people don't
we have to squeeze our dollars and hang
on because the world's filled with
people want to cheat us out of it but
teacher looked at me with Wonder but I
wasn't rebuked because she taught in a
Union town matta tues respond at local
23 of the all chemical and atomic
workers preachers and teachers knew to
cower when Port Arthur was in the middle
of a strike and blood had been spilled
at the plant gates my father Albert doll
straw there was a smouldering 230 pound
six-foot-two-inch khaki clad Lucky
Strike smoking hard muscle mal content
who sometimes lashed out in his sleep
and intruders trying to take away
something he had earned through sweat i
shadow box behind him learning to call
strikebreakers scabs where the corners
of my mouth turned down and occasionally
spitting in the grass I cared candy
lucky strikes in my shirt pocket what my
father hated I hated what he believed I
believed I what he believed I embraced
his universal truth so of course
Franklin Roosevelt was the father of our
country I learned to read from the
Seattle newspaper and from picket signs
see dick see dick strike strike dick
strike see Jane see James ticket picot
chain picot see Dick and Jane Dick and
Jane or Union
according to our code to budge off of a
truth in the face of an argument or to
compromise merely showed a lack of
character to forgive one's enemies was
for the pale-faced preachers and my
mother's church who pleaded for larger
collections and the sunday sermons my
father occasionally attended as the
price of peace at home we listed vigil
you those tear-stained sermons
especially closely when this communion
was on strike to make sure the preacher
didn't ask God for anything would give
aid and comfort to a scab or a
union-busting company strikes made
collection place all free light import
author and preachers were known to ask
for heavenly intervention when they
couldn't make the payment on the
church's new Ford the city of my birth
needed Jesus to help cushion its workers
against the climate of violence and its
fear of unemployment Port Arthur was an
acid smelling soot-covered Union town of
people who earn their living at one of
the local oil refineries or chemical
plants the city was a festering sore
that infest affected the Gulf the
marshes the bayous even the air smelled
of something singed and sour bosses
Republicans and professional people
moved to boma in 18 miles away import
author our houses looked the same we
dressed the same we even thought the
same because the center of our
collective universe was the all chemical
and atomic workers of local 23 when Pete
Seeger saying about ticky tacky little
houses all look the same he could be
talking about the houses and society of
port author all of our fathers made
within a few cents of the same salary
women didn't work our beaches were
covered with globs of all in the earth
around the banks of the narrow coastal
canal had the consistency of asphalt as
a result of dumped all his ship bilge
Democrats always received ninety-five
percent of the vote in 1951 was eleven
two friends Robert Jones and Earl
harbert peddle their bikes at breakneck
speed to our house we know where
Republican lives you want to go see I
jumped on my Western flower backing and
rode three or four blocks to a
nondescript frame house I don't like
where most of us lived we SAT across the
street in the shade of a Chatham berry
tree waiting finally a man a woman two
children emerged we were astonished they
look like us I don't know what we
expected but they didn't resemble
monsters who had sucked the blood from
working people either families to star
in fact the youngest girl was a
classmate of ours later true to my
father's father's predictions the
Republican became a scab when he
breached the picket line and entered
guffaws gates to work during a strike of
course we stopped talking to his
daughter at school and some of the boys
from high school broke her father's
winners and slashed his tires it was to
be expected what was unexpected however
was my father's lecture me when I
explained that we've shut the daughter
out of class activities rather proudly
you can't do that he said you go to
school and be nice that little girl she
can't help it if her daddy's a damn scab
and a snake she has to be born to such a
miserable son of a [ __ ] you said a good
example in school by playing without a
girl you hear me I did what my father
said was ridiculed by few of my friends
that's sort of my beginning but getting
in politics into my family to the
fundamentalist and my mother wouldn't
allow us to use words like heck or darn
because their oaths only substitute
words for damned in hell so we couldn't
use any words like that unless you were
talking about Republican it was a prefix
Republican Herbert Hoover Japs are Nazis
I didn't know Herbert Hoover's first
thing one damned until I was about 12
years old damn Republicans damn
depression damned Herbert Hoover at a
high school teacher was so ignorant she
didn't think the Herbert Hoover started
the entire global depression by himself
we've got into got in a great heated
argument that almost got me expelled
from the class but knowing she was in a
Union town she finally shut up when she
realized the wisdom of the I was
preaching I began my business in 1967 in
Baton Rouge after I've got my graduate
degree from LSU Dane my son was already
five years old his Dane here no dates
done here my daughter was almost four
I'd work for the Associated Press before
that but Louisiana's where I got my
training in the rough-and-tumble
politics and it's very rough and it's
very tumbled my first campaign how rules
for a woman mary evelyn Parker
I was asked to do it by the governor I
was very young I was in my middle 20s
and I didn't know what a political
consultant was they had no role models
had no idea but what I did was she had a
brand new Buick Riviera hardtop you know
you could roll the windows down there
was no center post it was kind of wide
open and I drove her around post to post
visit to visit a rotor speeches made her
television commercials good or
newspapering and she one day
particularly we went to this plantation
home well the plantation homes around
the Mississippi River this one's in the
middle of cotton field and they're built
about 12 feet have because the river
case are used to for the for the
engineers controlled it it would flood
so the houses had to be built up and all
these ancient plantations survived
because they were built high but there
was a Randall round and the ladies were
white gloves and they drank sherry and
they would all say no dear I don't drink
my will have a little sherry and they
would drink prodigious amounts of
gallons of it so i was a bit hungover
that day i don't remember why and i
drove the big Buick under an oak tree
because I didn't want to go up with the
ladies and for the fundraiser and i
turned the Buicks of the breeze came
through and all i could smell was
insecticides from the crop duster and
the cotton dust but it was better than
being upstairs and i was asleep and
someone grabbed me by the shoulder and
shook me it was a little guy about 55
wearing two pistols crossed like Matt
Dillon and a hat that made him about six
six or seven feet he said you the you
the driver for Miss Mary Evelyn and I
said uh nah but you don't argue with a
sheriff with two guns I said I was gonna
explain that was something noble I was a
political consultant I said yes sir I
Drive miss Miriam he said uh how do you
protect her
I don't know he said somebody comes at
her what do you do I said I don't know
he said can you should have gone I so
sure I'm a Texan you grew up I've lost
the hearing this air from shotguns of
course I can shoot a gun he said T Boyd
go to the squad car bring me that chrome
pistol we took off that lady deputy goes
back gets a pistol not that long
revolver Chrome he says got here and
shoot that stump let me see if you can
really shoot now shot the stuff once and
the missed shot again hit it hit it hit
it some point too far away sheriff was a
little drunk he thought was a wonderful
thing but the ladies came out on the
balcony and started applauding every
time I'd hit the hit the stump and so he
handed me the pistol he said he put that
under the seat because you might need it
and I put on the seat as far as I know
when they got rid of the car is probably
still under the seats in place but that
was that was sort of the beginning of my
career in politics and this book is
about the evolution the transition so I
came to I left Louisiana I could go into
a lot of a lot of other campaign store
some of them my wife would not send me
next time when not like for me to tell I
can't do say also in a couple of
brothels there's some pretty stores
there in the book you know bye-bye the
book her in the book so Russell long was
running for the US Senate a reelection
of course the son of Huey although no
one knew tooth damn because he had run
from his father's name for a long time
and he was challenged for the first time
ever and i did a 30 minute documentary
for him and he was very pleased and he
was so pleased he showed it to all his
friends up in Washington and they all
asked that I moved to a lot several mask
like Lloyd Bentsen that I moved to
Washington acting ad i did so an open my
office here over New Jersey Avenue and
he he sort of paved the way for me but
one day I was eating lunch with Senator
long and his hideaway off the rotunda of
the Capitol where the chairman of
Finance has a as a hideaway and a little
elegant old man burst through the door
very formal oh I am so sorry senator
long I
I'm so sorry I disturbed you I did not
know you were than another gentleman I
had an affair of state to discuss with
you Russell I'm winked at me he said
senator Stennis come meet my friend race
driver if you should run again and he
winked at me again you'll want his
services Stennis came up the table and
shook my hand and says what is it you do
sir well how do you tell what you do you
know it's a very complicated John's
business is complicated my business is
complicated there are a lot of pieces to
it so at best I could I talked about
research in media and campaign planning
and all those things he looked at me
said I think understand you're a
photographer and I said yes sir I'm
never one to argue my belief is agree
with everything work out the details
later sasa yes sir you said well I'm
gonna get this you had me walk up and
down in front of the Capitol and you
take my picture yes sir what do you do
with it I said I put it on television he
said never had much luck with that he
says send those things down there I
don't think they'd run him I so we pay
them Senate recent oh he said I bet that
makes a difference so what we had was
tomorrow and yesterday colliding here
and i find that story very interesting
because it's it's how the senate was and
how the senate was to be thinnest had
never run a campaign the most money it
ever raised his five thousand dollars so
in my regular meetings with and peter
hart was a poster and we had to gently
push this man into the in the 20th
century late 20th century anyway and
we'd meet with him and talk to him and
try to explain things to him he never
quite got it one day he said Mr
Charlotte how much money do you think
this is all going to cost me I said
about 2 million dollars senator this in
1980 22 million dollars he's have a poor
man he said I don't have two million
dollars he said I don't even have two
hundred thousand dollars he said I can't
campaign I said no senator you have to
ray
money he said but from who he said I
don't know anybody has that kind of
money I said well you're chairman of
armed services I said I suspect that you
couldn't call some of these aircraft
manufacturers and weapons manufacturers
and they would contribute and here's the
telling point he said sir don't know if
that would be proper he said I have life
and death of those people they come
before my committee there there's this
the government the money spends four
armlets comes through my committee is it
proper that I take money from them as
well senator won't you talk some your
colleagues about that and we'll get back
together somewhat to Senator Benson who
was everybody considers thinnest a
father figure they loved the old man he
was a man who had memorized the
Constitution at the University of
Virginia and at 87 could still recite
since our Constitution United States he
was amazing oh man that they turned to
when ethical crises so a few days Oh
talk to bens I told Ben somebody said
Raymond don't worry about the money so
just be nice to John Stennis and will
raise the money sir Russell long I'll
get the money together don't you worry
about it you only talk about a couple of
million dollars I knew was from Texas
where that's a small change but I got a
call one day centrist Center says mrs.
Crowley would you come over to my office
promptly and I said yes sorry so winter
overs office on him he was sitting
behind Harry Truman's table something
you get was seniority Harry Truman's
table is there is a beautiful thing he
loved it he would run the fingers over
and say old wood is so much better than
new wood he said you can see generations
in it and he was telling men himself and
he said up missed rather I've got a
great surprise for you I said what does
that he reached a nedestro and put out
an envelope proudly hand it to me said
look I opened it it was from LTV a check
from one hundred dollars he said I did
it I said you certainly did
and we uh we never asked him to raise
money again we won an award for that
film I did form a five minute film used
to we could do things of consequence we
go to 30 minutes we could do five
minutes we could run newspaper ads we
could do things and everything is 28
seconds but anyway we had this five
minute film I am moaning a little bit I
really saying short my age a little bit
we had this five-minute family we want
an award and I took it over i'm not much
on awards i don't keep those things and
i took over and gave it to senators
tennessee hung it on his wall and he
would tell people that came in that's
the award mr. Strether and i won
together and when he died that was the
war that was hanging on his wall in the
rest home so I've dear memories about
senator Stennis he helped me understand
yesterday in the decorum of the Senate
the way it was when they were gentlemen
called each other sir one day I'm
standing the hall with him and with
Senator Deacon Cindy of Arizona and an
aid comes back and since a dentist I
need to see a minute and Dennis T
consent he walked off in Central sistas
mr. Strether did you hear what he called
senator Deacon Seanie I said what sir he
said he called him Dennis called him by
his first name he said she shouldn't do
that and that was that was a different
Senate it was before it was a Senate of
good old boys I was forward/center port
was a center of acrimony so I always
treasure Stennis for that reason the
other thing that happened do you need
heat even you I need some water Thanks
hei Bai we're chanter so just get some
hot p as well the other thing that
happened is that our business began to
change here we had sitting in the front
row you're honest I don't want to be
true critical a great post or Dottie
Lynch you did the Gary Hart campaign
with me in 84 beautifully but anyway
when I began this business you had to
beg a candidate our posters they were
the tail fins on the Cadillac they look
nice it was a nice thing to have but
really $20,000 could be spent on bumper
stickers and when you don't
pole and finally I got prominent enough
that I could tell I could tell the
candidate it was a condition of
employment that they had to hire poster
if they hired me and we would hire
people like Peter heart and bill
hamilton to do polling for us and
another good poster there were several
of them and they would come in of course
they make the difference without polling
your dead duck they're awfully good so
my apologies to dot it because what I'm
about to say but polling pollies replace
leadership this country Poland's lowered
the quality of television commercials
because it's linear approach takes
emotional content out of it it sucked it
out completely and people who watch
television are turning it off a linear
approach to television can be nothing
more than words on the screen and the
posters are very very happy with that
because it answers all of their
questions and answers the data but it
doesn't move people now we have polling
running government bill clinton polled
to decide where he should take a
vacation i mean it's it's it's really
that serious there was once a time when
we stopped at the capitol steps and the
candidate went on alone we didn't do Kim
we didn't do government we did campaigns
recently not going to say how recent so
you know who it was a senator called me
and said why didn't you tell me this
would hurt my chances for reelection if
i voted for this bill i said senator I
don't do government I do campaigns
that's a decision you have to make will
straighten it out in the campaign if a
cause your problem but now we have a
little consultants and at the right hand
the president United States giving
advice
governing and campaigns have come
together and I worry about that I call
it the seamless campaign Russell long
told me one time sitting in his office
where they still had fires in the office
in 1980 in the finance office he said
you know the great thing about being a
senator I said what's that he said you
can be a statesman for four years and a
politician for two well unfortunately
now we have politicians for six years
and politicians for six years the
campaign starts the day after election
enormous needs of money you're no longer
you no longer can can the Congress is no
longer governed I think simply by the
conscience of the leaders leadership
spin replaced by numbers numbers have
brought both sides together they both
have well have st. polls Democrats and
Republicans why do you think the
Republicans now love the department
education they used to hate it why are
they putting social security in lock box
I used to try to dismantle it because we
all have the same attitudes now because
of poli do I wonder why you pulling no
I'd be out of business you can't have
that but there's somehow this country is
watering down its leadership and I worry
about that I'll read you one more piece
but all my rants are in the book and
there are a lot of rants but I try to
wrap around the ranch some stories that
make me happy and stories make me happy
I'm basically a storyteller my
television before posters got a hold of
me used to be storytelling it's not as
good as it once was I'm afraid so I'm
going to read the end of the book
a chapter called the chill winds of sep
tember and everybody Germans age and
what covers age we understand the chill
winds in September don't with Jack say
Jack says November how about octobre 13
right now jack so it's about I'm trying
to sum up my life and my business in
this chapter and I say I'm starting the
mill the chapter forgive me but you'd be
bored to death you've read the last
chapter Oh as soon as there's some great
chapter titles in here but I won't read
them but I had more fun writing chapter
titles and I had a write in the book
because of the influence of money and
people who raise it modern campaigns
resemble a corporate board meeting the
fundraiser also often sits on strategy
meetings along with a campaign manager
the press secretary some hack from the
party who has access to Washington money
the direct mail consultant a couple of
posters the candidate the candidates
spouse to scheduler and an occasional
relatives who once made used car
commercials this is a nightmare that
squeezes creativity out of the product
leaves the poster in charge and posters
should not create where Jack Martin
droid Benson and I would sit down and
make creative decisions on scripts and
spots I'd written there are now 10 or 15
people who consider themselves part of
the quote creative team it's no wonder
that all of America's political
commercials look the same and lack
appeal I guess I ran about the system
because I never lived up to my father's
ideas of helping people it wasn't what
we thought one redneck with bloody fist
and with his back against the honky Tonk
wall can't beat the system but it's been
an interesting life I didn't say
glamorous interesting occasionally I've
been disappointed in the quality that
people have helped elect and several
notable elections good decent caring
people were beaten by ten pot idols my
father thought good always prevailed if
one was willing to bloodiest knuckles
later I found we had no patent and what
was good or bad no matter what price we
paid there were shades of gray in
differences of opinion yet when
everything seemed
bleak I followed my father's blue moods
I think about the post-election mornings
and realized I not only made a
difference but if helped elect people
even my father would have been proud of
like the great governor of Georgia Roy
Barnes I find I'm having more and more
problems dealing with a defeat of good
people the money earned in losin races
like Joe Dawkins and Kansas turns to
ashes that gladly exchange for victory
but I guess I lived up to one of my
father's dictums one day in our small
boat out of sight of land in the Gulf of
Mexico my father was watching gulfs
throw themselves out of the sky to
capture shrimp that were headed herded
to the surface by hungry speckled trout
he broke one of his long blue silences
lamenting Raymond I hope when you grow
up you have things to regret I wasn't
absolutely sure then what he meant but
now i know that in his own way was
telling me to take chances not to be one
of those people who lived and died in
that gray area of the politically
correct and safe people who were content
to dog paddle through life only left the
world as they had found it the effect
change was to put yourself at risk he
knew this one lives on the edge mistakes
are possible he made mistakes I believe
he always regretted the violence at the
picket lines in his early life but there
was never doubt in his mind about right
in Rome a man had astounded stand his
ground on the picket line when the texas
rangers attacked with clubs and horses
he had to set an example for others when
your family lived only on vegetables out
of the small garden and your strength to
purpose my father was not a cruel man or
a bully he demanded that be kind to the
daughter of a scab he was outraged when
the innocent were hurt even when the
innocent were caught in the crossfire
between powerful forces once when I was
about nine and had my first Red Ryder BB
gun I shot a bird sitting on a limb it
fluttered dead from the cottonwood tree
and landed not far from my father's feet
where he sat in a rusted lawn chair
drinking coffee my mother had brought
out I was excited at the kill I'd aimed
I'd hit I'd killed did you see that shot
asked with enthusiasm yes why'd you kill
that bird I don't know what good will
come of it
I hung my head sorrow radiated from my
father sadness I don't know why I shot
it it'll never sing again and I like to
sit under the tree and listening to
birds by now wasabi not because of the
bird will cause my father never hurt
anything that doesn't hurt you never
shoot unless you really need food then
when you kill it eat it we cleaned and
cooked thats crony bird it was stringy
and went down hard I never killed
another songbird the same ol rusty chair
two decades later my father asked my
brother about similar question but why
he'd volunteered to go to Vietnam and
fly helicopters Claude I wish you
wouldn't go most people have never done
anything to us killing them will not
help this country in his 74th year he
was dying of cancer sitting in a signal
AZ bar rocker in the living room he
looked around and said I've lived all of
my life for that air conditioner that TV
said the Buick out said this old house
it's all come down to only that there
was a pause and the motor the wind air
conditioner seemed abnormally loud I
hope you do better they slept I hope I
did daylight ride now pardon my boys I'm
very apologetic them I'm filled with
things like coal remedies katni not
whiskey jack although that has happened
on occasion any questions I can answer
about my life in this strange land
yes and could you make a case that
polian was actually good for people in
government because it's so sophisticated
now that it does make them very much in
tune with people and there were two is
people this tends to enhance democracy
people are responsive to people hey
can't you make the case that totally
makes people more democratic makes
government more democratic because makes
government officials responsive to
people yes and no it's a good argument
my belief is this so i think leadership
shouldn't if you think of the body
public as an ocean and there are lot of
waves if you respond to every wave you
keep changing direction and i think
that's what's happening if you respond
quickly in politics to what's happening
today you're you're not allowing things
to take their course there's a natural
rhythm to things and I think leadership
if somebody stands for something they
can stand for it on day one and they
stand for it on day 235 and I think to
simply shift positions because the
numbers tell you to does it demonstrate
leadership and I always thought you were
elected to lead not to follow they call
it leadership and that's a good argument
about polling sure but if we polled
every day if everybody in America voted
they would change you know you could see
a movie about about cancer recovery one
night and vote for Medicare the next day
but two days later you don't care the
emotions of the voters go up and down
leadership should go on and on and
that's my opinion of it anything else
yes back to the back
local question do you have that many
dealings with Camille gourville nucla
meal prevail very well Camille burvelle
was an elegant operative in Louisiana
that spanned governor after governor
after governor he knew how to run
campaigns of that day I worked with him
with a governor named John McKeithen
later I worked with him with a governor
and Edwin Edwards who is now in jail
there are a lot of Louisiana politicians
in jail no I never went to jail was
never indicted oh no no but but no
Camille prevail never went to jail and
as far as i know was never indicted he
it was just a good political operative
you know he people depended on him and
he was very wise sure I know him well
hey Dottie yeah see any difference in
the way they approach campaigns are
going the question is do our women
candidates different than male can its
way they approach campaign the answer is
yes it would be politically correct for
me to tell you that no no you run
campaigns women just like you run
campaigns for men but it's not true
first of all somebody like me has to
become more flexible women women like to
have a lot of voices and normally in a
campaign for women you have more people
yet serve an accommodation you have more
people at the table with opinions and
they like to sort through them also you
have to overcome so many prejudices
against women by several groups one of
them being older women I find it very
hard to break through older women for
women candidates and you have to be
careful things that you don't with a man
i'm wearing a suit if I wore this suit
for the next three weeks no one would
notice that I changed that in change
suits I'm wearing a black pinstripe suit
when guys doing Martha Collins race in a
Kentuckian 83 we were doing extensive
focus group testing when we made
commercials and I would hear women say
if I see her in that blue dress again I
will not vote for her
so we had to be careful of dress might
be careful of jewelry well men don't
wear jewelry either so that's you know
that's the same thing but yet be careful
of the style the way they do their hair
we had a Evelyn Gandhi running in
Mississippi one time I don't remember
what year it was maybe 83 maybe 87 got
criticized because she changed glasses
the middle the campaign they said she
was trying to go high style and she was
being manipulated by this race Struther
guy really she just wanted to see
anything else Edward story I know you
have a few of those my favorite Edwin
Edwards story a lot of my can't tell ah
as Susan Feeny ah in PR this is a
gathering in satyrs and I'm thinking my
favorite headwaiter story that's good he
was a brilliant politician in a
brilliant man and in some ways almost
too smart because he knew he was smarter
than everybody who came came around and
only did one race for Edwards I did his
second race his reelection when he was
still known as a reformer and there are
two things I remember about Edwards one
when Governor John McKeithen left office
and Edwards replaced him I was standing
in front of capital with the ex-governor
about to be ex-governor watching Edwards
give his acceptance speech and he said
something that all politicians say I'd
love to be governor now because there's
really nothing left to do he said that
of course they all say that but he said
but he's kind of trouble I said why said
he's greedy he said the family's greedy
and I didn't know you know what that
meant but my favorite had whatever story
was one in so I did the second race and
we had it was a laydown race and he had
a lot of money and he told me do
anything I wanted to he didn't care but
don't bother him so I heard an artist
out of Connecticut named Bernard Fuchs
because Edwards was hard to pin down to
get on film Bernard fuchs is one of the
great illustrators and stills one the
great illustrators in America
and I paid a great deal of money to
bring him down I don't know seventy five
hundred thousand dollars two hundred I
don't know a lot of money to bring him
down he came down with his wife they're
very nice people he's incredibly
talented illustrator the year time and
time again so i told the state police at
the mansion that he was going to come
and they said yeah he's got to stay here
and they put him in the presidential
suite and about three o'clock or two
o'clock in the morning something I got a
call from Bernie Fuchs and he said I've
got a problem I said what said he said I
wife sitting with our suitcase on the
front steps we just got kicked out of
the mansion it's a kick alimentos very
embarrassing what happened he said mrs.
Edwards came in saying she didn't want
any strangers in her house and kicked us
out and it was that kind of conflict in
the Edwards family and organization that
constantly created problems for me one
time I was sitting in a fundraiser and I
don't know there were two or three
hundred people paying ten thousand
dollars a piece to sit there of course I
didn't and this very voluptuous
beautiful woman walked by stunning
Edwards was sitting on the dais with a
group of political hacks as you're
supposed to he watched her all the way
to the chair he said I didn't bring her
here she's not meeting me later I don't
know her asked rather who she belongs to
and that kind of went with a territories
attack anything else any questions from
back there at all thank you very much
everyone been a great pleasure and all
of you met sandy I'm sure and you will
and she's the one who made all this
adventure possible I want to say that
it's a to put up with me and the things
you read about in this book requires not
a woman but a superwoman and
occasionally she gets so tired of it did
there are consequences consequences this
book our marriage on the rocks up with a
twist can they be a challenge well so I
appreciate her being here she had to
come from Montana and she just came in
late we actually held a program for
couldn't start without her but I
appreciate a horse support through the
years it's been a great deal to me and
Raymond let me just say this I thought
it was interesting at the beginning
where you were talking about some of the
books like mr. Jews would Coburn Jack
Germans that I have a big impact but I
take when I read this book it reminded
me of a book that was completely
different but it was the first time I
felt like this about 50 15 years ago I
read a hundred years of solitude and
every every sentence you read you'd say
it's incredible the story in every
paragraph I'm telling you ray we just
read took two excerpts from there but
I'm said every paragraph in the book is
like that in you you don't want the book
to end well let me take one we wait for
the seat let me take one reason if you
believe that let me take one reason why
stand in the middle there back to the
room Carl cannon took this manuscript
yes and work the heck out of it it
really did call me on things call me on
facts jack germond back there read it
too and found that misspelled ronald
reagan's name
and it wasn't intentional I didn't do it
on purpose jack it just slipped through
but Carl Carl was a was super in this
thing all the way through what a would
call me and we'd argue about how to
express things and he helped me a great
deal he tightened this book up a great
deal and I'll be forever grateful to him
in fact in the beginning of it us I
actually say his name should be right
here along with mine because he did such
a great job with me now appreciate it
Carl very much but I had several really
good friends read the book like German
like like Carl and and also LSU press
did a splendid job I I went to LSU press
because I'm an LSU grant and I want to
do something that would help them and
this is the first in a series of books
on political communication that LSU is
going to publish and I'm proud to bend
the first be selected as the first book
and that's really why I went there and
they did it they've done a great job if
they would if LSU press would not have
started the Gulf War we have been
selling a lot of books because I was
signed I was lined up to do publicity
things everything once the war started
it all came to a screeching halt so uh a
lot of people for this book you know I
used to think that you did everything
alone that you're like John Fenmore
Cooper Cooper's American silent strong
American you didn't need committees or
anybody to help you and this I've gone
through life i found that you do need
people to help you you do need to help
and and you find helping from people
that that you help you find help from
people who count with you and you can
count on like John Jameson so I thank
all of you for tolerating me through the
campaign warrants for being my friend
for being an insider I prize and I
really very honored that all of you
showed up thank you
you guys we want to make sure that you
can leave after you've gotten a book and
a drinking some dinner so up late
raymond strother is author of falling up
how a redneck helped invent political
consulting it's published by Louisiana
State University Press on the web at
lsu.edu / LSU press